This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Oh, that's my phone. Sorry, let me just dismiss that. Producer James T. Green. Sorry, honestly, is this rare that I even keep my phone on vibrate or anything other than silent? It's kind of rare that I get calls at all. Yeah, because millennials are killing phone calls. I mean, well, kind of, but I can still remember a time which would phone calls.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马斯。哦，那是我的手机。抱歉，我把它挂断一下。制作人詹姆斯·T·格林。抱歉，说实话，我把手机设成震动或者不是静音的情况很少见吧？我基本很少接到电话。是的，因为千禧一代正在扼杀电话通话。我是说，好吧，某种程度上是这样，但我还能记起曾经有电话通话的时代。
Like, specifically when I was younger, probably around 15 years old. I remember family parties at my great-grandmother's house. The smells were that of pound cake and baked macaroni and cheese. The sounds were of gossip and complaints in bravado, but there's one noise that was constant and it came from my uncle
比如，特别是当我更年轻的时候，大概15岁左右。我记得在我曾祖母家举行的家庭聚会。空气中弥漫着磅蛋糕和烤通心粉加奶酪的香味。耳边充斥着八卦、抱怨和大话，但有一种声音是恒久不变的，它来自我叔叔
scooter or rather from his phone. See, family functions in my mother's house back then. Everybody left their cell phones on. Even before they blessed the food. See, scooter was the definition of a cool uncle. I remember wearing a lot of white even though our meals were pretty messy. He was a sunglasses indoors kind of guy. Sitting at the head of the table as he leaned back, the sunlight through the screen door would shine on his linked bracelet. And his flip phone was always clipped to his belt. Because Scooter got a lot of calls. Scooter was always getting up from the table to go to the corner of the room and whisper on the phone
斯科特，或者说来自他的手机。看呐，那时在我妈妈家的家庭聚会上。每个人都开着手机。甚至在谢饭祷告之前。看呐，斯科特就是酷叔叔的代名词。我记得我穿了很多白色的衣服，尽管我们的饭菜很容易弄脏衣服。他是个喜欢在室内戴太阳镜的人。坐在桌子首位，往后靠着，透过纱门的阳光照在他那串连的手链上。他的翻盖手机总是别在皮带上。因为斯科特有很多电话。斯科特总是从桌旁起身，走到房间的角落，对着电话低声细语
or step out on the porch. Sometimes he'd take the call right there in front of everyone. And we all remember the song his phone would play. It seared into my brain. My ringtone is This Woman's Work by Maxwell. Ah! Ah! Ah!
或者走到门廊上。有时他会当着所有人的面直接接听电话。我们都记得他的手机会播放的那首歌。它深深地烙印在我的脑海里。我的手机铃声是麦克斯韦的《这个女人的工作》。啊！啊！啊！
Ah! Ah! Ah! Ah! Ah! by Maxwell. Uncle Scooter had a lot of girlfriends, and so his phone, a hollow mono speaker, blessing Maxwell's smooth, neo-soul sound, rang all the time. It never went beyond the first few seconds, so you just hear the... before he flips open his clamshell phone. The song starts out, you know, he starts to scream. Ah! You know? So when this ringtone goes off around, people, it grabs their attention,
啊！啊！啊！啊！麦克斯韦的歌。斯科特叔叔有很多女朋友，所以他的手机，一个空洞的单音扬声器，播放着麦克斯韦圆润的新灵歌之音，整天响个不停。它从来不会超过最初的几秒钟，所以你只能听到……然后他就翻开他的贝壳手机。这首歌一开始，你知道的，他开始尖叫。啊！你知道吗？所以当这个铃声在人们周围响起时，它吸引了他们的注意力，
especially by me being a single man, he caught a lot of girls eyes and their ears too. And this is the time when everyone had ringtones. When the song your phone played really said something about you. I never had a ringtone myself, maybe for the same reason I never got a tattoo. I never wanted to commit to something so personal and so public. Yeah, ringtones were really meaningful and they could be different for all of your friends. I remember I'd scrolled to like my 15 contacts, figuring out what was the best ringtone to
特别是作为一个单身汉的我，他吸引了很多女孩的目光，还有她们的耳朵。这是每个人都有铃声的时代。手机播放的歌确实能说明一些关于你的事。我自己从来没有用过铃声，也许原因跟我从没文身一样。我从来不想对如此私密又如此公开的事情做出承诺。是的，铃声真的很有意义，而且它们可以针对你的所有朋友有所不同。我记得我曾滚动浏览大概15个联系人，琢磨着什么才是最好的铃声
sign for folks in my phone. Like what song would play when my best friend calls. Or my mom. And my crush. That's a whole lot of usher. I mean like who wasn't listening to usher at that time. But it wasn't just usher. You could go vintage with a timeless track, or you could grab a new single and change it
为我手机里的人设置。比如当我的最好朋友打电话时会放什么歌。或者我妈妈。还有我暗恋的人。那里面有好多亚瑟小子（Usher）。我的意思是，当时谁不听亚瑟小子呢。但不仅仅是亚瑟小子。你可以选择一首永恒的老歌来复古，或者你可以抓一首新单曲，换上
up with the newest Hattest song. These little 15 second melodies were these disposable yet highly personal trinkets. And it was all thanks to this guy. My name is Besamaktipanan, but every podcast was made by Sku. Besku is the father of the custom ringtone, which was conceived at a party in Finland in 1997. At that time I was a 27 years old and I was living downtown Helsinki and once it was really the night to go out, hang around with your friends and it was a gloom in November evening. Finland was in the midst of its Nokia inspired TechBoom and a lot of Vesku's drinking buddies worked in tech. And during
最新最火的歌。这些短短15秒的旋律是那些用完即弃却又极具个人特色的饰品。这一切都要归功于这个人。我叫贝萨马克·蒂帕南（Besamaktipanan），但播客制作的名字叫维斯库（Vesku）。维斯库是自制铃声之父，这个概念于1997年在芬兰的一场派对上孕育而生。当时我27岁，住在赫尔辛基市中心，一旦到了晚上，大家就会出去玩，和朋友们聚在一起，那是一个阴郁的11月夜晚。芬兰正处于诺基亚启发的高科技泡沫之中，维斯库的很多酒肉朋友都在科技行业工作。而在这些
these discussions, everybody was having their phones with them, what is the coolest phone, and showing the new stuff that you can do with that. You were like sitting around the table showing off. Showing off course, of course. Hey, what's the latest thing? Have you seen this that you can really do that kind of thing? Yeah, we were nerds, to be honest, we were nerds. But they were
讨论中，每个人都随身带着手机，讨论什么是酷手机，并展示你可以用它做的新东西。你们就像是坐在桌子旁炫耀。当然是在炫耀，当然。嘿，最新的是什么？你见过这个吗，你真的能做到那种事吗？是的，说实话，我们是书呆子，我们是书呆子。但他们是
nerds that knew how to party. So we were drunk, yeah. But the party wasn't really the thing. The whole inspiration and lighting came the day after, next morning, when you're in this kind of very a bit fragile mood. In other words, Vesku woke up hungover. And you have to find a way to survive the coming day. Glume, morning, windy, really windy morning and I was walking from my home and to the office, that's about two miles. It was cold and dark and my phone rang. I noticed this Nokia tune. Tididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididididid And then I decided, now it's enough. We gotta do something with this thing. If Vesku's phone was going to ring, it was going to make the sounds he wanted on his terms.
懂得如何派对的书呆子。所以我们喝醉了，是的。但派对其实并不是重点。真正的灵感和启发是在第二天，第二天早晨，当你处于这种非常脆弱的心情时。换句话说，维斯库醒来时宿醉了。你必须找到一种方法来度过接下来的日子。阴郁的早晨，有风，非常大的风的早晨，我正从家里步行去办公室，大约两英里路。天气又冷又黑，我的手机响了。我注意到了这个诺基亚调子。然后我决定，够了。我们得对这玩意儿做点什么。如果维斯库的手机要响，它就要按他的意愿发出他想要的声音。
I really wanted to hear Van Halen's jump. It's a power song. It would have been so much better to hear that. All that stuff. It's a positive song for me. An Eddie Van Halen, and he's a legend song for me, an Edi van Halen, and his legend with his guitar. So Vescu got to work trying to get Edi van Halen into his cell phone. The Nokia phones Vescu and his friends were using had this early text messaging function
我真的很想听到范·海伦（Van Halen）的《Jump》。这是一首充满力量的歌。听到那个会好得多。所有那些东西。对我来说这是一首积极的歌。艾迪·范·海伦（Eddie Van Halen），对F我来说他是个传奇，艾迪·范·海伦和他的吉他传奇。所以维斯库开始着手把艾迪·范·海伦弄进他的手机里。维斯库和他的朋友们使用的诺基亚手机有一个早期的短信功能
called Smart Messaging that let Nokia users send messages to each other. Vescu and his squad realized that they could compose ringtones in a program Vescoo created called Harmonium and then use that smart messaging platform to transfer bits of song as code to a cell phone. Let's put this way that the guys that I was working with, they were capable of doing all kind of cracking and hacking. Vescoo started fooling around on Harmonium and came up with the stripped down monophonic version of his favorite pump up jam.
叫做“智能短信”，它允许诺基亚用户互相发送消息。维斯库和他的死党们意识到，他们可以在维斯库创建一个名为Harmonium的程序中创作铃声，然后利用那个智能短信平台将一小段歌曲作为代码传输到手机上。这么说吧，和我一起工作的那些家伙，他们有能力进行各种破解和黑客攻击。维斯库开始在Harmonium上瞎琢磨，并想出了他最喜欢的打气歌的精简单音版本。
Vesco loaded the ringtone on his phone and he really wanted someone to give him a call when he was out in public and his big moment came on the way to a meeting on a packed rush hour train. Someone called his phone and jumped screamed from his pocket. Everyone in the train was staring at him and he loved it. The custom ringtone was born, but not everyone was going to be able to hack their flip phone the way that Bescu and his friends did. So he decided that he wanted to find a way to make custom ringtones easily accessible to the masses. Now we know that we can do that. And we have to spread the gospel.
维斯库把铃声加载到他的手机上，他非常希望在公共场合时有人给他打电话，而他的高光时刻在去开会的路上、一列挤满人的早高峰火车上降临了。有人打他的电话，口袋里传出了《Jump》的尖叫声。火车上的每个人都盯着他看，他喜欢这样。自定义铃声诞生了，但不是每个人都能像维斯库和他的朋友那样去破解他们的翻盖手机。所以他决定寻找一种方法，让大众能轻松获取自定义铃声。现在我们知道我们可以做到这一点。我们必须传播福音。
We have to provide this opportunity to everywhere and provide some kind of a service or application for anybody to be able to customize their ringtone. Vesco wanted everyone to be able to hear exactly the melody they wanted, so they could show off their phones and be the coolest nerd at the nerd party. And so he started pitching telephone companies on the idea of an application that would allow people to create, share, and download custom ringtones. And then one day, this finished wireless provider called RadioLinja said,
我们必须把这个机会提供给所有地方，并为任何人提供某种服务或应用程序，让他们能够自定义自己的铃声。维斯库希望每个人都能听到他们想要的旋律，这样他们就可以炫耀他们的手机，成为书呆子派对中最酷的书呆子。于是他开始向电信公司推销这样一种应用程序的想法：允许人们创建、分享和下载自定义铃声。然后有一天，一家名为RadioLinja的芬兰无线运营商说，
yes, they took Vesku's idea and scaled it up. The whole thing, the phenomenon, start to spread. It's like a meme. You are in a bus or train, commuting or whatever, and you hear a custom ringtone. And the first idea is that that's not the Nokia ringtone. Where the guy got it? Vesku's software allowed anyone with time on their hands to make their own musical ringtone
好，他们采纳了维斯库的想法并将其规模化。整件事情，这个现象，开始传播开来。就像一个迷因。你在公共汽车或火车上，上下班通勤什么的，你听到一个自定义铃声。第一个想法是，那不是诺基亚铃声。这家伙从哪弄来的？维斯库的软件让任何有空闲时间的人都能制作他们自己的音乐铃声
creations, but most people didn't have time on their hands. I would say that 99.9% of the people just want to have the ringtone in their phone. Which meant they needed a massive library of everyone's favorite songs in ringtone forum, and to build that library, they needed ringtone composers. Composers like Mike Levine, one thing that would take a lot of my time during the day was to think, how do I boil down a song with a lot of voices down to just one simple melody line. Mike worked for a ringtone company called Zinky while he was studying technology at NYU. He found the job listing on Craigslist, and he says that
作品，但大多数人并没有空闲时间。我要说的是，99.9%的人只是想在手机里拥有这个铃声。这意味着他们需要一个庞大的音乐库，里面装满了每个人最喜欢的歌曲的铃声版本，而要建立这个音乐库，他们需要铃声作曲家。像迈克·莱文（Mike Levine）这样的作曲家，白天花很多时间去思考的一件事就是：我该如何将一首有很多声部的歌曲浓缩成一个简单的旋律线条。迈克在纽约大学学习科技时，为一家名为Zingy的铃声公司工作。他在Craigslist上找到了这个招聘信息，他说
being a ringtone composer was kind of like being a translator, each tune with a little puzzle. This is something I have to think of like if you're doing a song, hey, ah, by outcast, you'd have to think of just that melody line. And do it in such a way where it would still communicate, you know, what the song was to folks. By 2004, Zingy was one of the biggest ringtone producers in the world. The company says it was selling 2.5 million ringtones a month. And these were basic, monophonic ringtones, simple bleeps and bloops, like this. Getting cell phones around the world to play a super stripped down version of Final Countdown
做一名铃声作曲家有点像当翻译，每个曲调都是一个小谜题。这是我必须思考的事情，比如如果你在做一首歌，嘿，OutKast的《Hey Ya!》，你必须只去想那个旋律线条。并以这样一种方式来做，它仍然能向人们传达这首歌是什么。到2004年，Zingy是世界上最大铃声制作商之一。该公司表示，它每月售出250万个铃声。这些都是基本的单音铃声，简单的哔哔声和嘟嘟声，就像这样。让全世界的手机播放超级精简版的《The Final Countdown》
might not seem that impressive today, but at the time, it required a huge amount of work, especially because each different brand of phone required its own custom soundfile. And so Mike and the composer said, Thingy had to program different ringtones for each phone manufacturer. And so we would have to create the same monophonic ringtone like 20 different times. It was enormously tedious. We had a whole bank of phones that we would use for testing these too. And all these were like bricks like huge phones
在今天看来可能没那么令人印象深刻，但在当时，这需要大量的工作，特别是由于每个不同品牌的手机都需要其自定义的声音文件。因此，迈克和Zingy的作曲家必须为每个手机制造商编写不同的铃声。所以我们必须把同一个单音铃声创建大约20次。这非常乏味。我们有一整排手机用来测试这些铃声。所有这些都像砖头一样，巨大的手机
But phones eventually got smaller and cheaper and the business model began to change Phone companies started giving away phones for very little money with the idea that they would make their profits on the Contract and other services like ringtones and that created a demand for better more musically complex ringtones. And that created a demand for better, more musically complex ringtones. Polyphonic ringtones started entering the market, and it was like, holly loo, we can create four different channels of audio. Amazing. And I was so just overjoyed to be able to create like actual kick drums and snare drums. Polyphonic ringtones meant that instead of one note at a time, you could get four notes at one time. And so the classic Nokia ringtone came alive in a blaze of
但手机最终变得更小、更便宜，商业模式也开始改变。电话公司开始以极低的价格赠送手机，其想法是通过合同和其他服务（如铃声）来获取利润，这催生了对更好、音乐性更复杂的铃声的需求。这催生了对更好、音乐性更复杂的铃声的需求。复音铃声开始进入市场，这就像是谢天谢地，我们可以创造四个不同的音频通道了。太棒了。能够创造真正的底鼓和小军鼓，我简直高兴极了。复音铃声意味着，不再是一次一个音符，你一次可以获得四个音符。于是，经典的诺基亚铃声在复音的荣耀中复活了。
polyphonic glory. With polyphonic ringtones, composers were able to move beyond code, and they didn't have to completely reprogram the song for every phone manufacturer. Now they can actually start using keyboards to map out their creations. If you're doing a rock and roll track, you have to decide how many of those four tracks you're going to give to the drums, how many you're going to give to, let's say, a guitar, bass line, and how many you're going to give to, let's say, a guitar, bass line, and how many are going to give to the voice? This was a golden age of the ringtone.
有了复音铃声，作曲家们能够超越代码，他们不必为每个手机制造商完全重新编写歌曲。现在他们实际上可以开始使用键盘来规划他们的创作了。如果你在做一首摇滚乐，你必须决定将这四个音轨中的多少个给鼓，多少个给比如说吉他、贝斯线，多少个给比如说吉他、贝斯线，以及多少个给声乐？这是铃声的黄金时代。
When composers like Mike Levine were cranking out their greatest works of ringtone art, Mike was actually responsible for one of my favorite ringtones ever. Back in high school, I was a huge Kanye West fan. I grew up outside of Chicago around the time that Kanye and Ringtones were both blowing up. Kanye's second album, Late Registration, had recently been released. Aside from the big singles like Gold Digger and Herdom Say, my absolute favorite song was a small cut towards the end of the album, Track Number 17. It's a slow-moving track with a dense orchestral build, almost like the falling action of the album.
当像迈克·莱文这样的作曲家创作出他们最伟大的铃声艺术作品时。迈克实际上负责了我最喜欢的铃声之一。回到高中时，我是坎耶·韦斯特（Kanye West）的超级粉丝。我在芝加哥郊区长大，正值坎耶和铃声都风靡一时的时候。坎耶的第二张专辑《Late Registration》最近刚发行。除了像《Gold Digger》和《Touch the Sky》这样的大热单曲，我绝对最喜欢的歌是专辑后半部分的一首短小曲目，第17首。这是一首节奏缓慢、管弦乐编曲密集的歌曲，几乎就像专辑的尾声。
The song is called Celebration. I love the production of this track. I felt like I was on screen starring in a movie of my life whenever I listened to it. It gave me confidence. Kanye Celebration was like the perfect musical representation of myself, which made it the perfect ringtone. ["Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh-Duh- it is. It's a celebration, bitches. So I couldn't, I couldn't not end that. Yeah. No, I'm highly certain that your version was probably the one I downloaded. Stop it. No way. Yeah, I'm pretty sure your your work was the soundtrack of my late high school years. This is amazing, James. That's probably the coolest thing I could imagine.
这首歌叫《Celebration》。我很喜欢这首歌的制作。每当我听它的时候，我都觉得自己是在自己人生的电影中出镜主演。它给了我自信。坎耶的《Celebration》就像是我自己的完美音乐写照，这使它成为了完美的铃声。它就是这样。这是一场庆典，碧池们。所以我不能，我不能不以此结尾。是啊。不，我高度确信你那个版本可能就是我下载的那版。别这样。不会吧。是的，我很确定你的作品是我高中晚期的配乐。这太棒了，詹姆斯。这可能是我能想象到的最酷的事情了。
Oh my God, I love it. I love it. Oh, fan of my work here. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
哦，天哪，我喜欢它。我喜欢它。哦，我这有你作品的粉丝。对。对。对。对。对。
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. In a short period of time, ringtones became a booming business, but using all these popular songs meant companies like Zingee needed to get the rights to them. So, a lot of my recollection of my time there was working in a very fast pace like, we need to be the first to get the sounds, let's do it, let's figure out who has the rights,
对。对。对。对。在很短的时间内，铃声成为了一门蓬勃发展的生意，但使用所有这些流行歌曲意味着像Zingy这样的公司需要获得它们的版权。所以，我对那段时光的大部分回忆都是在一个非常快节奏的环境中工作，比如，我们需要最先获得这些声音，我们干吧，弄清楚谁拥有版权，
let's go get them. That's Stafi Ibrahimach. She has the rights, let's go get them. That's Stacey Ibrahimhatch. She handled the licensing over at Singy. There was a content team that identified all the hot songs that were coming out. They gave folks like Stacey a heads up, and then she went into action. They say, hey, this new song is going to drop by X-Artist, and we need to make sure that we have the ringtone rights the data farm drops. And so oftentimes our job was feverishly trying within the space of hours to figure out
我们去把它拿下来。那是斯塔菲·易卜拉欣哈奇（Stafi Ibrahimach）。她拥有版权，我们去把它拿下。那是斯黛西·易卜拉欣哈奇（Stacey Ibrahimhatch）。她在Zingy负责授权工作。有一个内容团队负责识别所有即将问世的热门歌曲。他们给斯黛西这样的人发出预警，然后她就采取行动。他们说，嘿，X歌手将要发布这首新歌，我们需要确保在唱片发布时我们拥有铃声版权。所以通常我们的工作就是在几个小时内疯狂地试图弄清楚
which publishers and labels owned rights to certain songs had to get those rights. All these forces, the licensing, tech, and the business, came together to usher in the final fully evolved form of Ringtone. The Real Tone Real tones were basically just snippets of the song cut down the size. Like Uncle Scooter's Ringtone, it was just that Maxwell's song. It was the closest thing to listening to music on our phones in the mid-2000s.
哪些出版商和唱片公司拥有某些歌曲的版权并必须获得这些版权。所有这些力量——版权、科技和商业——汇聚在一起，迎来了铃声的最终完全演化形态。真实铃声（Real Tone）。真实铃声基本上只是被剪短的歌曲片段。就像斯科特叔叔的铃声，它就是那首麦克斯韦的歌。这是2000年代中期我们在手机上听音乐的最接近的方式。
And as cool as it was to finally hear music on your phone in high fidelity, for composers like Mike, it was hard not to see the rise of the real tone as something of a loss. Once we got the rights to the actual songs and once the technology got savvy enough, we became much more editors at that point than anything else. We missed getting to actually get into the nitty gritty and create the audio ourselves. And that bleepy, bloopy ringtone aesthetic was gone forever. Ringtones were just music now.
尽管能在手机上高保真地听到音乐很酷，但对于像迈克这样的作曲家来说，很难不把真实铃声的兴起视为一种损失。一旦我们获得了实际歌曲的版权，并且一旦技术足够精明，我们在那个时候就变得更像是剪辑师，而不是别的什么。我们怀念那种真正深入核心、自己创作音频的时光。那种哔哔嘟嘟的铃声美学永远消失了。铃声现在只是音乐了。
Even the classic Nokia ringtone. And once you could put any sound on a phone, why limit yourself to music? Our largest market were like younger, mostly boys, based on a lot of like polling data that we had. And so I created a ringtone called burping cow, farting donkey. That's some classy stuff. farting donkey. Buzzer. Buzzer. Buzzer. Buzzer. Buzzer. That's some classy stuff. I used to bring home just myself, like 3, 4K a month,
甚至经典的诺基亚铃声也是如此。一旦你可以在手机上放任何声音，为什么要把自己局限于音乐呢？我们的最大市场是年轻人，主要是男孩，根据我们拥有的大量民意调查数据。所以我创作了一个名为“打嗝的牛，放屁的驴”的铃声。这可真够小资的。放屁的驴。蜂鸣器。蜂鸣器。蜂鸣器。蜂鸣器。蜂鸣器。这可真够高级的。我以前光靠自己带回家，大约一个月3、4千美元，
just selling this stuff, you know? I joke around that it's the opposite of Edison's formula. This is like 99% inspiration, 1% perspiration. Because these take like a matter of minutes to create, you know, I would just find examples of a donkey and like farting noises. I was about as dumb as it sounds. With millions of cell phone users buying real-tone pop songs and donkey farts, ringtones became a cash cow and not just for the cell phone companies.
就靠卖这玩意儿，你知道吗？我开玩笑说这跟爱迪生的公式相反。这就像99%的灵感，1%的汗水。因为这些东西只需几分钟就能制作出来，你知道的，我就会去找驴子和放屁声音的样本。我当时就像听起来那么蠢。随着数百万手机用户购买真实铃声流行歌曲和驴屁声，铃声成了一台摇钱树，而且不仅仅是对手机公司而言。
Also, for the music industry, which was struggling in the early 2000s. In the early 2000s was the rise of file sharing, both of legal and illegal kinds, and this helped to cause a major decrease in music recording industry revenue. And so the ringtone was seen as a way of kind of making up for that. This is Samantha Gopentath. He's a professor of music theory, and he wrote a whole book about the ringtone industry. Gopentoth says that real tones became an increasingly valuable piece of intellectual property for music publishing companies. Who owns a song is the publishing company, and so it's the publishing company that gives
对于在2000年代初期苦苦挣扎的音乐产业来说也是如此。2000年代初期是文件共享兴起的时期，包括合法和非法两种形式，这导致音乐录制产业收入大幅下降。因此，铃声被视为弥补这一损失的一种方式。这是萨曼莎·戈彭塔思（Samantha Gopen-Tath）。他是一位音乐理论教授，他写了一整本关于铃声产业的书。戈彭塔思说，真实铃声成为音乐出版公司越来越有价值的知识产权。拥有这首歌的是出版公司，所以是出版公司给予
you permission to, you know, kind of essentially use the material of the song. The real tones, which were actual snippets of the songs, allowed the music industry to have more control, so they were able to charge a higher price and get a bigger cut. The real tone may have helped the music companies, but it ended up being the beginning of the end for the ringtone industry. The custom ringtone met its demise,
你许可，你知道的，基本上可以使用这首歌的素材。真实铃声是歌曲的实际片段，它让音乐产业拥有了更多的控制权，因此他们能够收取更高的价格并获得更大的分红。真实铃声可能帮助了音乐公司，但它最终成为了铃声产业走向终结的开始。自定义铃声迎来了它的消亡，
according to Samant, for a few reasons. As smartphones improved, people just started using their own MP3s as ringtones. It became much easier to just copy them and get them on your phone. Also scammers got into the ringtone business and started scaring off the customers. But the biggest reason was that it just became too much. If everyone had their own cell phone with their own little cute ringtone, public spaces got really noisy. Ah!
根据萨曼的说法，原因有几个。随着智能手机的改进，人们开始直接使用自己的MP3作为铃声。复制它们并弄到手机上变得容易得多。此外，骗子也进入了铃声行业并开始吓跑客户。但最大的原因在于，它变得太过火了。如果每个人都有自己的手机，带着自己可爱的小铃声，公共场所就会变得非常吵闹。啊！
Ah! Ah! Ah! Ah! Ah! Ah! And so everyone just started putting their phones on vibrate. There is a kind of social policing that's really has also taken place to reduce sort of public phone communication practices and the ringtones to no decline is a part of that.
啊！啊！啊！啊！啊！于是大家开始把手机调成震动。某种社会监管也随之发生，以减少某种公共电话交流的做法，而铃声的衰落正是其中的一部分。
Fones became more functional, texting got better and faster and more convenient. Our phones became full-on pocket computers and entertainment devices with headphones. People are using their phones as part of creating kind of private auditory bubbles for themselves. In this well the end for ringtone companies like Zinky and ringtone makers like Mike. I'll be honest by like mid-07 it became an almost daily expectation. We knew this axe was gonna fall anytime. we just didn't know when it was gonna come. And everybody was just thinking we're all making good money here. Let's just enjoy it while it last. Unfortunately for Mike, the axe fell just as swiftly as he feared. I believe as of September or October of 07, it happened. And our new CEO at that time came around and basically fired our whole
手机变得更加实用，短信变得更好、更快、更方便。我们的手机变成了名副其实的口袋电脑和带有耳机的娱乐设备。人们正在使用手机为自己创造某种私人听觉泡沫。在这个世界里，像Zingy这样的铃声公司和像迈克这样的铃声制作人走到了尽头。老实说，到了07年中期，这几乎成为了一种每天都在预期的事。我们知道这把斧头随时会掉下来。我们只是不知道它什么时候会来。每个人都在想，我们在这里都赚了不错的钱。趁它还在，好好享受吧。不幸的是对迈克来说，这把斧头像他担心的那样迅速落下。我相信在07年9月或10月左右，它发生了。我们当时的首席执行官过来，基本上解雇了我们整个
concert group. It was about 35 to 40 people let go at once. The day the music died. Yeah, it was not a happy day. Over a decade later, our phones are touchscreen screened many computers that never leave our sides. They are our music players, our televisions, our portal to the world. And in a way, it all kind of started with Vescu, and his need to have Van Halen on his flip-fon. We prove that there is such thing as a mobile entertainment.
制作团队。大约有35到40人同时被解雇。音乐死的那一天。是的，那不是快乐的一天。十多年后，我们的手机成了从不离身的触屏迷你电脑。它们是我们的音乐播放器、我们的电视、我们通往世界的门户。在某种程度上，这一切都始于维斯库，以及他想要在自己的翻盖手机上听到范·海伦的渴望。我们证明了存在移动娱乐这回事。
There's a business there, and it will change the old world. Vesco remembers his little place in history every time his phone rings. Let me see, it's switched my phone on here. It's now the polyphonic ringtone, it's just an MP3 file that plays when Vesco gets a call. But it's still something he holds on to as a form of self-expression. I think it's been there... at least 15 years. I'm a Kajtefa myself, so for me surfing the USA is also a statement that I'm a sofa. And Vesco isn't the only one still using custom rings.
那里有商机，它将改变旧世界。每当电话响起，维斯库都会想起他在历史上的那一小席之地。让我看看，我的手机在这切换了。它现在是复音铃声，当维斯库接到电话时，它只是一段播放的MP3文件。但它仍然是他作为自我表达的一种形式而坚持的东西。我想它已经在那儿了……至少15年了。我自己是个冲浪爱好者，所以对我和我来说，《Surfin' U.S.A.》也是一种声明，表明我是一个冲浪者。维斯库并不是唯一一个还在使用自定义铃声的人。
Mike, the former ringtone maker, is now a student of musicology at the University of North Carolina. And his ringtone screens, student of musicology who still thinks about ringtones. I have been using Radiohead's idiotec, actually, for a while, which I think makes a really good ringtone. And don't forget about my uncle Scooter.
前铃声制作人迈克现在是北卡罗来纳大学的音乐学学生。而他的铃声放的是，一个仍然想着铃声的音乐学学生。实际上，我用Radiohead的《Idioteque》已经有一段时间了，我认为它是一个非常好的铃声。别忘了我的叔叔斯科特。
His ringtone 16 years later is still that Maxwell song. In my day, when you got something, you hailed onto it because it was hard to come by. So when you got something, you learned to take care of it and treasure that. And I guess it carried over into my adulthood, especially with something that you like. I love this ringtone and I held on to it for a dear life. And I'll probably have this ringtone until I die.
16年后，他的铃声依然是那首麦克斯韦的歌。在我的年代，当你得到一样东西时，你要紧紧抓住它，因为它来之不易。所以当你得到什么东西时，你学会了照顾它并珍惜它。我想这种习惯延续到了我的成年期，特别是对于你喜欢的东西。我喜欢这个铃声，我拼死抓住了它。我可能会一直用这个铃声直到我死去。
I may not have a Maxwell ringtone on my deathbed but after reporting this story I decided I'm not going to keep my phone on silent anymore. I'm using ringtones again, and I think a lot about which ringtone to use on a given day. My default is one of my favorite yay-ay-ass song, one that represented a pivotal moment of my life, and it brings me joy every time a telemarketer calls. If I travel, I'll switch it up to match wherever I'm going. Kind of like how someone reads a book about the place that they're visiting. If I'm in the DC area, I may switch up my ringtone to a gold blank song. The week that MPR's morning edition changed their theme song, RIP, I made my ringtone the original theme.
我临终时可能不会用麦克斯韦的铃声，但在报道了这个故事后，我决定不再让我的手机保持静音了。我又开始使用铃声了，而且我经常思考在某一天该用哪个铃声。我的默认铃声是我最喜欢的坎耶的歌之一，一首代表了我人生关键转折点的歌，每次有电话推销员打来时它都会给我带来快乐。如果我旅行，我会换掉它以配合我要去的地方。有点像人们阅读一本关于他们正在访问的地方的书。如果我在华盛顿特区地区，我可能会把铃声换成一首古老的歌曲。NPR的《晨间新闻》更换主题曲的那周，RIP，我把铃声设成了原版主题曲。
I think of ringtones kind of like a NAML pins or tote bags or baseball caps. They're a simple way for me to show off my tastes in an increasingly templatized world. So, a modest suggestion here for the next time you got in public. Take your phone off vibrant, load up your favorite song, something that says something about you, turn the volume up, and wait for a robot's camera to call. 1 nd 2 nd 2 nd 2 nd
我觉得铃声有点像珐琅徽章、手提袋或棒球帽。在一个日益模板化的世界里，它们是我展示品味的一种简单方式。所以，对于下次你进入公共场合，我有一个小小的建议。把你的手机从震动调出来，加载你最喜欢的歌，一首能代表你的歌，把音量调大，等待一个推销机器人的来电。1 nd 2 nd 2 nd 2 nd
2 nd 1. Draw the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line the line of the line of the line the line of the line the line of the line of the line the line of the line of the line the line of the line of the line of the line the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the line of the The horrible things that happened when we hit peak ringtone in the 2000s after this. So Joe Rosenberg word on the street is that you have a ringtone story. I do. I do. I have a ringtone story. It's my one and only ringtone story. And it's not about my ringtone. I should just say that straight off. And it takes place in this golden era of ringtones. It's not about my ringtone, I should just say that straight off. And it takes place in this golden era of ringtones.
2 nd 1. 在2000年代我们迎来铃声巅峰时发生的那些可怕的事情，将在之后播出。所以，乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg），街头传言说你有一个关于铃声的故事。我有。我有。我有一个铃声故事。这是我唯一的一个铃声故事。而且它不是关于我的铃声。我一开始就该这么说。它发生在这个铃声的黄金时代。它不是关于我的铃声，我一开始就应该直说。它发生在这个铃声的黄金时代。
It's circa 2004, I'm a senior in college, and it takes place in, you know how like every college has that kind of student lounge area where there's just like a bunch of sofa chairs and the heat has turned up like five degrees warmer than everywhere else because like the nominal excuse is that you're there to study, but really you're there to sleep. And there's just all these kind of sleepy undergrads kind of dozing off in the oversized chairs.
大约是在2004年，我是一名大四学生，事情发生在一个，你知道就像每个大学都有的那种学生休息区，里面有一堆沙发椅，暖气开得比其他任何地方都高个五度左右，因为名义上的借口是你去那里学习，但实际上你是去睡觉的。那里有各种各样的、昏昏欲睡的本科生在超大的椅子上打瞌睡。
Totally. Right, and like the golden rule of one of these places, of course, is like silence. It's like the one place besides, I guess, the library where it's a silence rule. And so anyways, I went in there to like study slash sleep and I found a sofa near the roaring fireplace. And I start to kind of, you know, I sit down, I'm starting to kind of doze off. And, but just before I kind of actually fall asleep in earnest, I hear this tinny recording of a voice similar to the voice of Alicia Silverstone in Clueless and it's going, excuse me, your phone, it's ringing.
完全是这样。没错，这种地方的金科玉律当然是保持安静。除了图书馆之外，这是唯一一个有安静规则的地方。无论如何，我走进去学习加睡觉，我在噼啪作响的壁炉旁找到了一张沙发。我开始，你知道的，坐下来，我开始打瞌睡。但是就在我真正沉沉睡去之前，我听到一个细小的录音声音，听起来有点像《独领风骚》里艾丽西亚·希尔维斯通（Alicia Silverstone）的声音，它在说：不好意思，你的电话，在响。
And I'm like, what is that, right? And I look around and there is a cell phone on the coffee table directly in front of me completely unattended. It's ringing and this is its ringtone, is this voice. And then it continues and it's like Excuse me. I still don't know why you're not picking up the phone because it's really annoying And this is the phone. This is the ringtone of the phone. This isn't someone talking to you
我就想，那是什么？我环顾四周，正前方的一张咖啡桌上放着一部手机，完全无人看管。它在响，这就是它的铃声，是这个声音。然后它继续说：不好意思。我还是不知道你为什么不接电话，因为这真的很烦人。这就是那部手机。这就是那部手机的铃声。这不是有人在跟你说话
Next to you selling you to pick up the phone. Yeah. No precisely. This is the phone itself. This is this is the the real tone recording Coming from the little tini speaker of the phone projecting itself towards me, urging me a total stranger to pick it up. And there's no one attending to the phone. I'm the only person near it, right? And it's really loud. And so everyone in this, you know, commons area is starting to like look and turn towards me, right?
在你旁边叫你接电话。是的。不，确切地说。这就是手机本身。这就是那部真实铃声录音，从手机小小的微弱扬声器里传出来，向我投射，敦促我这个完全的陌生人去接听它。而且没有人照看这部手机。我是唯一一个靠近它的人，对吧？声音很大。所以这个公共休息区的每个人都开始看着我并朝我转过身来，对吧？
And now the phone is like, excuse me, I think you really need to pick that phone because it's ringing, right? And everyone's looking at me, the person next to the phone, and like kind of getting these desters, like, yeah, buddy, the phone is ringing. Why aren't you picking it up? Right? And I'm like, I don't know what to do because it's not my phone and I don't know how to communicate this and I'm trying to be like, I'm sorry, it's not my, I'm just kind of like, but meanwhile, like, the phone's ring is like getting more and more irritated with me. Right? I mean, like, I don't understand why you are not picking up the phone because it's really annoying and it's still ringing. Right? And at this point, like, people are like coughing, you know, making like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like, like,'s just like, why don't you just pick up the phone already because it has been ringing off the hook non-stop. And this one I'm just wondering,
现在手机就像是：不好意思，我觉得你真的需要接那个电话，因为它在响，对吧？每个人都在看着我，这个挨着手机的人，然后做出那种手势，好像在说：嘿，老兄，电话在响。你为什么不接？对吧？我就想，我不知道该怎么办，因为这不是我的手机，我不知道该怎么表达这一点，我试图表现得像，我很抱歉，这不是我的，我只是有点像，但与此同时，电话的铃声对我也越来越恼火了。对吧？我的意思是，就像，我不明白你为什么不接电话，因为它真的很烦人，而且它还在响。对吧？在这一点上，人们都在咳嗽，你知道的，发出那种声音。就像，为什么你不赶紧接电话，因为它已经响个不停了。这时候我只是在想，
how many rings has it been set to? Is this person set it to go to voicemail after 12 rings? But so anyways, finally, I'm like, fine, fine, fine, I'll pick up the phone. And I pick it up, right? And I can see that you can reject the call, right? And I pick it up, I reject the call. And I'm like, okay, great, I did it.
它被设置成了响几声？这个人是不是把它设置成响12声后转入语音信箱？不管怎样，最后，我觉得，好吧，好吧，好吧，我来接电话。我把它拿起来，对吧？我看到你可以拒绝来电，对吧？我把它拿起来，拒绝来电。我想，太好了，我做到了。
You know, I had to stop for a night and I was like, and just right after I do that, I hear this voice behind me, say, excuse me, what are you doing? And I turn around, I look behind me, and I see this young woman who is just looking at me utterly perplexed. And she's like, why are you holding my phone?
你知道，我不得不停下来过夜，我想，就在我做完那件事后，我听到身后传来这个声音说：不好意思，你在干什么？我转过身，向后看，我看到一个年轻女性正满脸困惑地看着我。她说：你为什么拿着我的手机？
Right. And I'm like, oh, I'm sorry, I had to reject the call. And she's like, she's like, you did what? It's like, well, it was ringing. So I had to reject. She's like, you picked up my phone and decided to reject my call. Why would you do that? Why would you ever pick up someone else's phone? It's an incredible violation of privacy. Right? And now like everyone's watching us. Right?
对吧。我说，哦，对不起，我不得不拒绝来电。她说，她说：你做了什么？就像，嗯，它在响。所以我不得不拒绝。她说：你拿起我的手机，决定拒绝我的来电？你为什么要这么做？你怎么能随便接别人的手机呢？这是对隐私的难以置信的侵犯。对吧？现在每个人都在看着我们。对吧？
And I'm just, I don't know what to say. Because I don't know. I'm like, because the situation is already so like, strangely complicated to explain how I got to the rationale by which I would feel justified in picking up her phone, turning it off, which she just doesn't understand at all, because she just wasn't there. Right.
我只是，我不知道该说什么。因为我不知道。我想：因为这种情况已经非常……奇怪地复杂，很难解释我是如何得出这样一种逻辑的：我觉得自己有理由去拿她的手机并把它关掉，而她根本无法理解这一点，因为她当时根本不在场。对吧。
And so I'm just stumbling all over myself and she just continues to break me about how incredibly presumptuous this has been, kind of violation of privacy. How could I ever do such a thing? And so finally, I'm, I just go, you know what, I'm so, I'm so sorry, I'm just gonna leave, right? And I like put the foot, I put the phone down
所以我当时语无伦次，而她还在继续数落我，说这有多么自以为是，简直是侵犯隐私。我怎么能做出这种事？最后我实在受不了了，就说，你知道吗，我很抱歉，我还是走吧，对吧？然后我把脚...把电话放下了
and just like kind of like embarrassingly, squawks slash scurry away. And like in a way that like if I were Hugh Grant, it would be charming, but I'm not. So it's actually just utterly like awkward and humiliating, do you know what I mean? Totally. And I still remember this scene more vividly and remember it more frequently than any other kind of comparable scene of embarrassment, like in my entire life.
然后像个做错事的人一样，狼狈不堪地溜走了。这种感觉如果换成休·格兰特来演可能会很迷人，但我不是。所以实际上这只是彻底的尴尬和丢脸，你知道我的意思吗？完全是这样。而且直到今天，我依然比我一生中任何其他类似的尴尬场景，都更清晰、更频繁地想起这一幕。
Huh. So why do you think that is? So I thought about this a lot actually. And I think it has to do with this concept. Are you familiar with this term? It's a German term called, I'm going to mispronounce it, but trepon vits. No. So trepon vits kind of mean stair width. Sometimes it's called stair jokes, stair words. And it's the idea of you've been humiliated somehow in public, you've lost an argument,
哈。那你觉得这是为什么呢？其实我经常琢磨这个。我觉得这和一个概念有关。你熟悉这个词吗？这是一个德语词，叫...我可能发音不标准，叫 trepon vits（台阶回味）。不。所以 trepon vits 有点像是“台阶宽度”。有时也被称为“楼梯笑话”、“楼梯词”。它的意思是，你在公众场合受到了某种羞辱，在争论中落了下风，
and like six hours later, as you're walking up some set of stairs, like the perfect comeback occurs to you. Oh, so I see, I see stair width. So like the width that you come up with while walking up stairs away from the scene, yeah, I got it, yeah. Midstep and you kind of stop and pause. And you're like, I got it. Yeah, I got it.
结果大约六个小时后，当你正走在某段楼梯上时，那个完美的绝佳回击突然从你脑海里蹦出来了。哦，我明白了，我明白了，“楼梯宽度”。也就是说，你离开现场走在台阶上时想出来的宽度，对，我懂了， yeah。走到半步你突然停住，顿了一下。然后你心里想：我绝了。对，我想到了。
Mid-step and you kind of stop and pause. And you're like, oh, god. Only I had said this. And of course, every time we do this, we always spend the next five minutes like kind of honing this comeback. Right, yeah, we're shopping it. Yeah, we're shopping it.
走到半步你突然停住，顿了一下。然后你心里想：天哪。我要是当时这么说了就好了。当然，每次我们这样的时候，接下来的五分钟我们总是会不断地打磨这个回击。对，没错，我们在脑子里演练它。对，我们在反复咀嚼它。
Yeah, we're shopping it. Saying it out loud, giving ourselves a little performance and then until we really, really just have the perfect comeback and we can pat ourselves on the back. And on some level, when we do this, we can poke fun at it and say that's kind of petty of us and kind of silly and we're just stroking our fragile egos. But I actually think this idea of treponvitz,
对，我们在反复琢磨它。大声说出来，给自己来一小段表演，直到我们真的、真的想出了完美的绝招，然后我们就可以自我感觉良好了。在某种程度上，当我们这么做时，我们也可以自嘲一下，觉得我们这人挺小肚鸡肠的，挺傻的，不过是在抚慰我们脆弱的自尊心罢了。但我其实觉得 treponvitz 这个概念，
this idea of coming up with the comeback later, actually does serve a kind of healthy psychological purpose, which is it allows you to get over this thing, right? It allows you to kind of put it behind you and put in its place and walk away kind of with your ego-healthily intact. Right. And I think one of the reasons I've never forgotten this scene and why every time I think about it and I think about it way too often. It just continues to hurt me in this way that is disproportionate to its actual importance. It's because I've never thought of the perfect comeback.
这种事后才想出反击的想法，实际上确实起到了某种健康的心理作用，那就是它能让你释怀，对吧？它能让你把这件事抛在脑后，把它安顿好，然后带着完好无损的自尊心昂首离开。对的。我想这也是为什么我从未忘掉这一幕的原因，也是为什么每当我想到它——而且我想它的频率实在太高了。它依然会以一种与其真实重要性完全不成比例的方式伤害我。那是因为我从来没有想出过完美的绝地反击。
It's such a complicated. Totally know what you mean. It's such a complicated situation with so many layers that would require so much explanation to actually like get the person up to speed to explain to her the context and the exposition and everything such that she would understand the situation such that I would be able to then deliver the comeback that it's almost like uncom back I just, and so, and so it's actually, I've never been able to kind of purge it,
这真是太复杂了。完全明白你的意思。这是一个如此复杂、层次丰富的局面，需要大量的解释才能让对方明白当时的上下文、背景以及各种前情提要，以便她能理解当时的处境，然后我才能顺理成章地给出那记回击，以至于它几乎成了一个“无法回击”的死局。我只是...所以，所以其实我一直没能把它彻底从脑子里清除出去，
it's, and it's, I had taunted me to this day. But I will say, there's something else about this incident that didn't occur to me until we started working on this story, which is that this was something that could've only happened at this moment in history circa 2004. So obviously this is a real tone, right? It's a real tone, it's a recording of a woman's voice.
它一直折磨我到今天。不过我要说的是，关于这次事件还有另一件事，直到我们开始制作这个故事时我才意识到，那就是这件事只能发生在历史上的那个特定时刻，大约是2004年前后。所以很显然，这是一个真实的手机铃声，对吧？这是一个真实的铃声，是一个女人声音的录音。
It's not polyphonic, it's not monophonic, and it's much more than the donkeys farting, category of things than it is in the music category of things. But what it is is that I'm kind of stuck at this moment where two historical forces, one being like, an unstoppable force and the other being an movable object are about to collide. And one of these forces, you definitely need
它不是复调的，也不是单音的，它更接近“毛驴放屁”这类恶搞事物，而不是音乐类的东西。但它的奇妙之处在于，我正好卡在了这样一个时刻：两股历史力量，一股是不可阻挡的力量，另一股是不可移动的物件，它们即将正面碰撞。而其中一股力量，你绝对需要
your own custom ringtone. And the other forces, everyone else's custom ringtone is really annoying and everyone just needs to turn them off. Right? Totally. And this was happening right around this time, 2003 to 2005. And I got caught in the middle in between these two forces colliding because with this ringtone that is addressing this very issue, it is like the ultimate meta-self-reflexive,
你自己的个性化铃声。而另一股力量则认为，其他所有人的个性化铃声都烦死人了，大家赶紧把它们都关掉吧。对吧？完全是这样。这正是2003年到2005年这段时间发生的事情。而我正好夹在这两股碰撞的力量中间，因为这个正戳中这一痛点的铃声，简直就是终极的元自我反讽，
scary movie 5, this trend is over, all we can do is point to the form itself and declare ourselves superior to it. Right, you know, and so basically this ringtone is saying like aren't ringtones annoying, right? And in fact, yes they are. And, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and in the case of this one. And so this is something that could only have happened to me in this incredibly narrow window of time, when this kind of hagelian dialectic of ringtones and no ringtones, you know,
就像《惊声尖笑5》一样，这种潮流已经结束了，我们能做的只有指出这种形式本身，并宣布我们在它之上。对吧，你知道的，所以基本上这个铃声是在说，铃声不是很烦人吗，对吧？事实上，确实如此。而且，而且，而且，而且，而且...就这个铃声而言。所以这只能发生在我生命中这个极其狭窄的时间窗口里，当时这种关于铃声与无铃声的黑格尔式辩证法，你知道的，
thesis, antithesis collides, and created something new in its wake. That's all I got. So if one of the problems with this story is that you never come up with the perfect comeback, the perfect Chappin vets, to ease your mind, to assuage this sort of lingering mortification, maybe we should figure one out for you. You know, like, I don't know if I don't think I can do it. But the collective mind power of the people who listen to this show, maybe they could come up with a good comeback for you.
正题与反题相互碰撞，并在其废墟中创造出了某种新的东西。这就是我的全部故事。所以，如果这个故事的问题之一在于你从来没有想出过完美的绝地反击，也就是完美的 Chappin vets（台阶回味），来宽慰你的心灵，缓解这种挥之不去的羞辱感，也许我们应该为你想一个。你知道的，我不知道，我觉得我自已搞不定。但听这个节目的听众们汇聚起来的集体智慧，也许能为你构思出一个精彩绝伦的回击。
So if you were in the situation, and you were being brow beaten by somebody who didn't want you to answer their phone, even if their phone was ringing, and unaccompanied in front of you, what should you say back? Okay. Let's see what we do. It's great. It's great. It's great. It's great.
所以，如果你当时处于那种情境中，正被一个死活不让你接电话的人训斥，即便对方的电话就在你面前响个不停，毫无应答，你应该怎么回击过去？好吧。让我们看看我们能做些什么。这太棒了。这太棒了。这太棒了。这太棒了。
It's great. It's great. It's great. It's great. It's great. It's great. 99% Invisible was produced this week by James T. Green, edited by Avery Trouffleman and Emmett Fitzgerald.
太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。《99%隐形》本周由詹姆斯·T·格林制作，埃弗里·特劳夫曼和埃米特·菲茨杰拉德编辑。
Mix and Tech Production by Sherefusif, Music by Sean Rial. Katie Mingle is our senior producer, Kirk Cole-Stat is the digital director. The rest of the team is Joe Rosenberg, Delaney Hall, Chris Barube, Vivian Lee, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7K, LW in San Francisco, and produced on Radio Row, in beautiful, downtown downtown Oakland, California. 99% of visible is a member of Radio Topia from PRX, a fiercely independent
混音与技术制作由 Sherefusif 负责，音乐由肖恩·里亚尔创作。凯蒂·明格尔是我们的资深制作人，柯克·科尔-斯塔特是数字总监。团队其他成员包括乔·罗森伯格、德兰妮·霍尔、克里斯·巴鲁贝、维维安·李、索菲亚·克拉茨克，以及我，罗曼·马尔斯。我们是旧金山 91.7K LW 的一个项目，在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市市中心的 Radio Row 制作。99%隐形是 PRX 旗下 Radiotopia 的成员，这是一个充满独立精神、
collective of the most innovative shows in all of podcasting. Find them all at radiotopia.fm. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet trapping vids at me at at Roman Mars, and the show at 99PI or a grown Instagram and read it too. But you can download a set of original music composed for this episode by Sean Rial and use it as your personal ringtone at 99PI.org. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
汇聚了播客界最具创新性节目的集体。请访问 radiotopia.fm 了解详情。你可以在 Facebook 上找到本节目并参与讨论。你可以在 Twitter 上@我 Roman Mars，也可以@99PI，或者在 Instagram 和 Reddit 上找到我们。你还可以下载由肖恩·里亚尔为本期节目创作的一套原创音乐，并在 99PI.org 将其设置为你的专属铃声。Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. Radio tapio. 本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。